foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Ted gays please report to the
principal's office that's up to you guys
tonight is our night we're getting the
couch I'm gonna talk to Brittany you get
that Isabelle what would I say hey girl
how's your boyfriend how's his penis
[Music]
I'm gonna expel you both for committing
a crime against Jeff get out of the car
you can't tell me
[Music]
like a Fight Club yes just stay in your
lane into your munching Beaver Wesleyan
yes sir
what's your plan here Jeff is psychotic
and they're picking on the weak and
defenseless so we teach a bunch of girls
how to defend themselves they are
grateful to us adrenaline is Flowing
next thing you know Isabelle and
Brittany are kissing us on the mouse
you can be our club advisor you know my
mom did say I need to pick up a hobby
Club
face [__]
[Music]
I want that trophy
a safe space like this it means a lot to
people I'm gonna finally reverse stalk
my stalker yeah I'll be able to kill my
stepdad awesome he seems so supportive
of women especially the hot ones
man-made therapy
are you cheating on me no I literally
saw you yesterday sub nerd I [__] your
mom
[Music]
your Club is over
they deserve a shot at showing everybody
how [__] cool they are
some fun places
I know y'all ain't tickling the Pearl I
just don't know if you're supposed to be
talking to us like that just like as the
teacher